foreign
we were in the studio last week and we
came up with this new rule I'm at first
was calling it the reverse packing party
rule because when Ryan did his packing
party which you saw in our last Netflix
documentary he boxed up all his things
as if he were moving he spent the next
21 days unpacking only the items he
needed right so he's kind of hid all of
his possessions but sometimes that's
what we do in our houses with our
drawers and our cabinets and our
credenzas and other spaces that hide our
clutter our closets our addicts Etc and
so I'm calling this the out in the open
Rule and it's a reverse packing party
for your stuff that is hidden we came
into the studio and Ryan was here
Professor Sean was here from Alabama was
here I was here and what we did is we
emptied out our little closet over here
that keeps all of our equipment our
cables our pins our pencils our paper
our envelopes our tissues anything that
we use regularly or think we might use
regularly we keep it stored away in
these drawers right and so if you'll see
when we put it all here on the floor TK
and if you're watching the video version
of this on the private podcast you'll
see it above my left shoulder here we
sent this photo to you last Friday as
well nice we got everything on the floor
everything out of the cabinets literally
everything emptied them out completely
we got everything what out in the open
yeah hence the name for this is the out
in the open Rule and as soon as we put
everything out in the open what did it
do it forced us to deal with everything
because we're gonna either have to put
it away there are a few things we were
able to sell most of the things will
either donate or a few things we're
actually holding on to trash why why
we're the minimalists why do we have all
this stuff so if you're looking at the
photo here on the screen or if you just
listen to the audio version I'll I'll
say a few things we have here like we
had a few mic stands obviously we use
those regularly we had some cleaning
solution we used that and then there was
a bunch of like extra cables this pile
of cables in the back it's like hey we
never use these cables here's another
pile of things that we used to use but
we don't don't use them anymore and so
getting everything out in the open I
applied this to my home last week
and because I was talking to Ella about
everything that she owns and she's like
I just love stuff and and I'm like do
you use some of your stuff I use all of
I play with all of it I'm like really
and like we start getting some stuff out
and I'm like when's the last time I
believe that oh I don't play with that
anymore and as soon as she realized that
it took away the clingy you get it out
in the open and sunlight becomes the
metaphorical disinfectant here as soon
as you see it I don't need to hold on to
this anymore I can let it go and it made
putting the things back so much more
manageable my gosh yes it was very
satisfying to be able to reorganize
those cabinets because there were so
many things that were useful a year ago
or you know six months ago
but our needs change over time the
studio changed all of our preferences
kind of got tweaked a little bit that
was incredibly helpful for my OCD
so I found that doing this at home even
with relatively organized closets or
drawers or whatever getting the thing
out of its normal environment out of
your clothes closet even though yes I
wear those things sometimes getting it
out putting it on the floor getting that
linen closet everything out of it just
throwing it on the floor okay what do I
actually want now that it's out in the
open what do I want to put away what do
I want to hold on to what am I going to
get value from and what do I need to get
rid of right now because it is simply
getting in the way of the things that
add value
the question stands
yeah
yeah
because
if it's not adding value to my life
it's clutter
and the thing that wasn't clutter a year
ago might be clutter today clutter
simply means that it's getting in the
way so one man's clutter is not clutter
for the next man one woman's clutter is
not clutter for the next woman right and
so by bringing it out in the open I'm
able to more easily Let It Go why
because I can't just hide it it's not
out of sight out of mind it's Insight
it's in my mind right now and it's
creating the mental clutter until I get
rid of it like an unripened banana that
becomes ripe and edible
and like a gallon of milk that becomes
spoiled
clutter can become valuable treasure
valuable treasure can become clutter
because all things change with time hmm
you could do this with relationships get
all your friends in a room
[Laughter]
wondering why I gathered you all here
today
oh man it's you know when it's
interesting though because
um obviously that's a joke I can invite
all your friends over so you could pick
and choose who you want to hang out with
but there is some truth in uh doing that
with relationships for me it's the best
new rule of decluttering that we've come
up with since the 16 rules for living
with less great which you can download
for free over at the minimalists.com but
we've introduced some new rules since
then as well like the didn't know rule
but that actually pairs well with this
so if you get everything out in the open
quite often it's like I didn't know I
owned this I didn't know I owned this
but now it's out in the open and if you
didn't know you owned it that's another
sign to go ahead and let it go because I
didn't miss it before I'm not going to
miss it now did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free